[Music]
in philip jose farmers novella the
lovers one of the most interesting parts
of the world building has to do with
ideology with ideas that are lived out
as a
particular philosophy also as a religion
with its own metaphysics
and hal yaro the main character of the
work is somebody who has been brought up
within this religion but is not
not having a particularly good time with
it he is a believer
but he's you know he's got some worries
some
questions that he can't actually get
answered but he is also living it out
and it's through eventually
talking with the waggle bug fobo he's
able to extricate himself
from it to the degree that he is so
we've got this guy isaac
sigmund and actually he gets invoked you
know as sigmund preserve us right as an
uh a important religious figure he is
the forerunner
in this religion and he's credited with
writing important texts like the western
talmud as it turns out it's got almost
nothing to do with the earlier
jewish talmuds or anything like that and
philip jose farmer clarifies in an
interview that isaac sigmund is actually
icelandic he's one of the people who
came from from iceland and um you know
that's part of the hijack
we could call it political community the
hijack confederation of survivors of the
great apocalyptic war
and sigmund produces this extensive
belief
system
that is spread across the entire hijack
union and it has some important
behavioral components to it but here
we're mostly interested in the belief
component so it's a belief system and
it's structured like a salvific religion
it's you know it gives you sort of a
guidance in life about how to make your
way towards what's good or is we're
going to talk about what's real and away
from what's what's bad or unreal
and as in many systems there's a good
guy there's also a bad guy
sigmund's brother is is the you know the
the bad person in this sort of like the
devil
it's also structuring an entire
political community and you could even
say not just political but pedagogical
community
in which
people are brought up and there's all
sorts of aspects
to that that reinforce it
now
we get a little vignette of this very
early on with hell and he's thinking
about how things are not working out for
him with his wife and and his job and
he's you know he's got this mr this
rating that is going down and he says oh
sigmund sigmund of course is the
originator of this religion why can't i
be content with things as they are why
can't i accept reality fully why must i
have so much of the back runner in me
tell me tell me and what is the
background the backgrounder is the bad
guy the one who makes things
unreal the one who suggests to us
ways of living or choosing or doing or
speaking that go against the
forerunner's vision
now hal himself as we find out in his
discussion with fobo actually
discussions because these go on for
quite a while
um
hal has questions
and there's this really interesting
discussion that's that's going on that
we're going to come to and look at a
little bit more closely in a bit here's
the point that we want to think about
right now
hal says
i have thought about that very question
fobo says did you ask anyone
no hal said feeling trapped we were
allowed to ask questions of course of
our teachers but that question was not
on the list now this is an incredibly
revealing feature of this
belief system as it has evolved
fobo says you mean to tell me your
questions were written out for you and
you were confined to those
well why not hal said angrily those
questions were for our benefit the
sturch knew from long experience what
questions students ask so it listed them
for the less bright less bright is right
said fobo and i suppose that any
questions not on the list were
considered too dangerous too conducive
to unrealistic thinking how nodded
miserably so there are some questions
that are
allowable and then there are other
questions that are
out of bounds that could get you into
trouble that can lead you down the wrong
path
and nobody really knows
who's got those questions in their mind
because you can't
bring them up this is another way in
which the
system is constructed to you know sort
of keep people within it mentally
you know there's actually a name for
something that consists of a list of
questions that are allowable and then
the proper answers to it
we call that a catechism
a teaching document that is often used
by churches but could be used by all
sorts of others as well and it's got the
prescribed questions and then the right
answers
all this does is reinforce belief rather
than provide intelligibility let alone
promote intellectual you know
dispositions such as curiosity or
systematic thinking and so for a lot of
people including how doubts and
speculations and problems do arise
but those can be explained in terms of
the influence of the back runner and
there is this view that
anything that you do that's bad or wrong
is because of the influence of the back
runner or the devil or the agent of evil
and chaos within you that you're giving
into
the central category of this entire
way of thinking
is something that's actually going to
raise some problems if you think it out
philosophically
reality versus unreality we go back to
that statement of hails or prayer rather
why must why can't i accept reality
fully what is it to accept reality fully
is it to be a passive
uh
you know recipient of just what's in
front of you and not make any judgments
or
is part of the human reality that you
have to make judgments but they have to
be the right kind of judgments right so
this is going to be a very
problematic issue and we see
over and over again people bringing up
you have unreal and it could be
thoughts it can be desires it can be
actions we want to keep you from
committing an unreal act his wife mary
says to him uh you know and what what is
an unreal act well this requires us to
do a bit of thinking we'll come to that
in a moment words unreal statements
unreal
you know things that you say and even
unreal futures and all of these are
connected together the one who desires
to engage in an unreal action is trying
to move into an unreal future and you
could say well
if it's unreal
how how then can it actually
be and this is the problematic really
pun intended what is being meant here
instead of reality is something like
goodness or
truth or
being in line with the teachings of
sigmund and his followers and
interpreters and i and i think that
that's what you have to
substitute in there because consider if
you had an uh if you had a unreal desire
how do you define an unreal desire well
it's an it's for an unreal future or for
an unreal act what would be an unreal
act
um you know one great example would be
engaging in the kind of sex that they do
jeanette and hale in the lovers with the
lights on enjoying yourself together you
know even though it is of course
prescribed by by sigmund the goal would
be to have uh procreation with without
the orgasm and desire and all that kind
of stuff so just just wanting to have
sex with somebody who you're in love
with by itself would be looking for
an unreal act to be well engaged in by
both of you right an unreal
collaboration or commingling
unreal futures get brought up quite a
bit as well and the idea is to steer
people into thinking that there's one
real way of doing things there's even an
intimation
that sigmund as he's traveling
throughout time to make things real that
part of what that would mean
is that he overcomes the very reality of
time there's places in there where hal
says oh we all travel subjectively
through time sigmund traveled
objectively and he said what does it
actually mean
and there's a little bit of hinting
about what that could could be and it
sounds like
turning you know
turning time off
although that's not really followed out
now there are a lot of different
distinctions between
types of reality that get brought up and
this is this is quite interesting so
hal
is going to um talk about
here we go
as he's sitting by himself he's kind of
he's kind of uh mulling things over he
says
the forerunner had described what his
reaction should be or had he done so
directly when hal considered that
section of the western talmud which was
read only by engaged and married couples
he saw the forerunner had not actually
depicted a physical state his language
had been poetical hal knew what poetical
language meant for as a linguist he had
access to various works of literature
forbidden to others or it was
metaphorical even metaphysical couched
in terms which analyzed were seen to
have little relation
to reality now that would be a big
problem like the forerunner is not being
real himself
forgive me forerunner thought hell i
meant that your words were not a
scientific description of the actual
electrochemical processes of the human
nervous system of course they apply
directly on a higher level for reality
has many planes of phenomena and here we
get to this listing
sub-realistic
realistic
pseudo-realistic surrealistic super
realistic retro-realistic we don't get
that this is like the exclusive list of
course but there's a lot of different
ways of being real that are being
brought in here
and hal says to himself no time for
theology no wish to wake make my mind
whirl again tonight as on many nights
with the unsolvable unanswerable the
forerunner knew but i can't all he knew
now was that he was not in phase with
the world line had not been possibly
never would be he teetered on the brink
of unreality every waking moment and
that was not good the back runner would
get him he'd fall into the forerunner's
brother's evil
hands right so this is this is a good
depiction of
what's happening we've got all these
different
mixed together
modes of reality or unreality and this
is kind of you know an unclear matter
that is never truly
clarified one way in which we do get to
see this
being
made a bit more concrete
is through the problematic of will or
choice and now this comes up in terms of
like the freedom of the will
when um hal and and fobo are talking
about
uh the religion and science of the
hijacks right
this passage is the way he says although
we didn't know it he was himself being
cured by fobo his almost daily talks
with the empathist installed doubts fobo
read the biographies of isaac sigmund in
the works the pre-torah the western
talmud the revised scriptures the
foundations of serialism time and
theology the self in the world line
there's a lot of interesting books being
mentioned here with suggestive titles we
don't actually know what's what's going
on in any of these parts but he says
that sigmund's reasoning was buttressed
by too many false analogies metaphors
and strained interpretations
fobo says let me point out one more in a
score of contradictions embodied in your
theology and here he's going to talk
about responsibility but before this or
after this rather he talks about free
will he says
if you disagree with the starch or try
to defy it you do so because you're
trying to realize a pseudo future right
a
pseudo reality something that's not real
one condemned by the search you the
individual can't win
but you also believe that you yourself
have perfect free will to determine the
future but the future has been
determined because sigmund has gone
ahead in time and arranged it sigmund's
brother jude changer may temporarily
disarrange the future in the past but
sigmund will eventually restore the
desired equilibrium so let me ask you
how can you yourself determine the
future when the future has been
determined and forecast by sigmund one
state or the other
may be correct but not both and this is
the very question that hal says yeah
i've actually thought about that a lot
but unfortunately that wasn't one of the
allowable questions on the list that we
got to ask our teachers so i don't know
this does seem to be a
big flaw
within the system on the one hand
everything is determined
and you know even the things that
are wrong aren't even real they're
pseudo futures even as you're realizing
them
on the other hand
you can act freely you're completely
free and that's why you're responsible
you poor bastard for what it is that you
do and here we get to the individuals
and their responsibilities so
we see this getting played out we'll
come back to this discussion between the
two but we'll see this played out in
the crash that takes place
out in the jungle and what they they
think about it we could also say that
you know
hal and his his wife in the very
beginning mary not having children is
viewed as
him
not being willing to commit to that
future so that's his own fault as well
because mary wants it to happen
and
[Music]
his gapped person holds him responsible
so there's a car crash and person who's
this gap sort of think about like a
commissar a political officer who's in
charge of you and also a spiritual
director and he's kind of a sadistic guy
but he portrays himself as loving you
know and and and just wanting the best
for things
so poorson says you say
or he says how do you explain this
accident um
and hal says i or rather the back runner
and me departed from reality i my dark
self willingly precipitated a pseudo
future making that pseudo future the
future they encountered
poorson says oh really you say your dark
self the backrunner and you did that
that is what you have said ever since
you were able to talk
why must you always blame someone else
you know
you should for i have been forced to
whip you many times that you and you
alone are responsible when you were
taught that it was your dark self that
caused departures from reality you were
also taught that the back runner could
cause nothing unless you
your real self hal yaro fully cooperated
so there's a locus of freedom right
and hal says
that is his ship meaning true as the
forerunner's left hand but my beloved
gapped
you forgot one thing in this little
lecture of yours
you were in the accident too therefore
you caused it just as much as i did
porsen said but you were driving the car
and hal says makes no difference
according to what you've always told me
you agreed to be in the collision
if not if you had not we would have
missed the beast
so you know
yarrow is actually bringing up something
that he's imposing some consistency on
this system of thought that has been
brought up before
over and over again and imposed on him
whipped upon him by
this this you know jerkish person
uh the gap
fobo in their discussion says let me
bring up this this contradiction you
sigma knights believe that every person
is responsible for any event happening
to him that no one else but the self may
be blamed if you hal yaro stumbled on a
toy left by some careless child happy
happy infant with no responsibilities
and skinned your elbow
you did so because you really wanted to
hurt yourself
if you are seriously hurt in an accident
it was no accident it was you
agreeing to actualize a potentiality
contrarily you could have agreed with
yourself not to be involved and so
actualized a different future
if you commit a crime you wish to do so
if you get caught it's not because you
were stupid in the commission of the
crime or because the azites were more
clever or because circumstances worked
out to make you fall in the hands of
what is your vernacular for them the us
no it was because you wished to be
caught you somehow controlled the
circumstances if you die it was because
you wanted to die not because someone
pointed a gun at you and pulled the
trigger you died because you willed to
intercept the bullet you agreed with the
killer that you could be killed so this
is you know quite an interesting
way of understanding freedom and
metaphysics and agency and passivity and
suffering right and fobo goes on and
says
here's the thing
of course this philosophy this belief is
very shib for the starch for it relieves
them of any blame if they have to
chastise or execute or unjustly tax you
or in any way take uncivil liberties
with you
obviously if you did not wish to be
chastised or executed or taxed or dealt
with in an unfair way you would not
permit it
so that's you know
a key idea there you you are not only
you know
if you accept this belief system
whatever happens to you you're choosing
it you're responsible for it
the very agency that imposes this upon
you
you've also
not just accepted
but
collaborated with that you've chosen it
and so you know
it's in some ways consistent but it also
ultimately becomes
incoherent and they're thereby
inconsistent
and what we see is that
farmer is is presenting this to us as
part of the way in which the world or at
least the part of the world that hal is
coming from the hijacked confederacy
uh
part of how they think through things
it's a guiding ideology but he's going
to be freed of it and we're supposed to
look at as readers and you know say wow
this is some interesting philosophy but
one that's ultimately
deeply
problematic
within this this framework and
it's not just that
it's okay within this framework it's
also a problem for the characters
themselves within this very framework as
we we see
you